nice work Santiago thank you sir Peralta
figured out the pattern though so he
should get credit for the collar have
you seen him I sent him home he
assaulted Jimmy Brogan yeah but that
caveman kind of had a coming don't you
think oh he didn't tell you tell me what
nevermind if Jake didn't tell you he
must've had a reason it's not my place
I'm disappointed in you Santiago I
thought you and I were close I know
you're manipulating me but I love it and
I will tell you anything so Jake went to
the schvitz to talk to Brogan what you
gonna do about it
[Music]
there's nothing I can do except to ask
you nicely as a fan of you your work and
the guys you wrote about
please don't print the quotes unless
you're gonna get your panties all in a
pretzel that's actually not technically
possible I'm not wearing underwear and
just swap in here my butt's like the
Everglades look I know you're trying to
be legit in a head of bag world so I
will not print your quote oh thank you
thank you that means the world to me and
for the record I know that Holt is a
stickler but he's actually a really good
cop don't worry about that we're friends
you don't have to stick up for that homo
I really wish you just said that welcome
home oh thank you Santiago that'll be
all they're just Leslie Hey hey this is
my boyfriend Derek this is Derek's
boyfriend Ben Hey
oh wait sorry what's the situation what
do you mean how does this work
Derek is gay but he's straight for me
but he's gay for Ben and Ben's really
good for Derek and I hate Ben it's not
that complicated not oh yeah sure
the thing about youth culture is I don't
understand it
listen man I'm so sorry I had no idea oh
it's fine no it's okay it's why I just I
feel terrible about it I have been
calling people [ __ ] since I was in
junior high and I have never made this
mistake if I don't know how to behave it
is because I am just so far the opposite
way you know I'm just I I can't even
imagine saying maybe we could go out for
a beer sometime and you could tell me
how you do that to another dude
that sounds like a great wonderful idea
let's do that
[Laughter]
it explains so much
no I'm not gay and I don't understand
why anyone would think that I'm gay if
yeah I'm getting sergeant all of these
are fine how much longer you gonna work
on this it's questions like that that
made van Gogh cut off his ear
you can't put a clock on art ten minutes
great let's catch this guy's doing give
hold some good news I want to cheer him
up well how do you even know he's in a
bad mood I mean it's impossible to read
that guy this is the most incompetent
worthless report get your act together
or so help me God you won't live to see
retirement it's like what's that guy
thinking you know I can read him and if
anyone can figure out what's bothering
him it's me he and I are exactly the
same except that I'm younger Cuban
female single and straight captain
Holt's not gay come old Kate seriously
man just retire
hey why are you all dolled up oh it's a
long story
I'm the guest of honor at this gay bar
tonight I guess gay men are starting to
like me I don't know I guess they think
I'm fabulous or something oh you look
good girl you gonna turn somebody
tonight
[Laughter]
can you tell us gay and who's not
of course what about Oscar absolutely
not well he is well he's not dressed in
women's clothes so there could be others
I need to know I don't want to offend
anybody else you could assume everyone
is and not say anything offensive
yeah I'm sure everyone would appreciate
me treating them like they were gay hey
what about Angela she's hard and severe
she'd be a gay woman I really don't
think so
I don't know I can imagine her with
another woman hey you do some research
find out if there's a way to tell by
just looking at him Jim told me you
could buy gaydar on mine that's
ridiculous
no probably you didn't tell the truth a
lot let's call him get the website
definitely when gay marriage was
legalized we weren't sure if or when it
was gonna be struck down so speed was of
the essence
do you Kevin yes and to you yes yes we
do we're married I remark afterwards
that I wish the old ficient had been
more efficient it was very funny Kevin
still talks about it huh maybe I should
hope it with that there's a bar nice she
called pitchers and catchers and you go
there
here's the plan our position is we have
no position so let's just say thank you
for the party but we were dreadfully
decline your offer to honor oh my god I
can't believe you came nope you're my
hero
Leslie you are looking hot nice but I
need to tell you something this one is
on us well if it's free
Leslie No
she's left-wing up she likes to recruit
you
[Applause]
I would just like to say thank you so
much for throwing me this party
especially on a night when the Colts are
playing
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
I've seen so many dudes from city Hager
tonight's crazy but I guess they've seen
me here too so that's not great
[Applause]
you don't like tonight's fun with
everyone so gay and they know how to
have fun and the dancing just it's
everyone is just who they are and who
they are is just stone cold gay
I'm a poker face bang I've met many
interesting people and there's two
bisexual guys here and I got both of
their phone numbers no we're all
sleeping in one room next to a cow orgy
much rather be hanging out with you what
are you doing boy not you Becca I was
talking to Charles just bringing some
water
Thanks mm-hmm so uh you talking to tell
your mystery hunk yeah it's fine I'll
call you back later
what is that a woman's voice it's my
sister wait she called you babe
well my kids called me babe you said
relatives shouldn't do that what's
really going on I'm dating a woman I'm
bi oh that's great that's great rude I
just want you to know that I totally
support you want to talk about it right
now okay just leave it alone
Boyle not you Becca okay I love you too
you